oh no I'm curious how many of you tried
drawing this thing they don't have a guy
okay now let me suggest to you look I
make you do it now in fact I'm not even
gonna do myself because you can't do it
without it but I'm very surprised that
if you try to work out what is it the
two of these derivatives both of the
gradient functions are the same even
though the functions look pretty
different to me gradient tells you
something about what it looks like
palette behaved okay so as a problem
solving strategy in general I think it
would have been a nice idea if you
actually gave it a go and so what's
going on here
what about if I've done this what would
you expect
now you might guess I think it might be
the same David and you'd be right there
Christian ey now before actually I'm
sure you I'll tell you the reason why
this is trickier why it's a bit weird
and why only like a third of you put
your hands up as yeah I'm sure it's
right
oh sure I can explain it but I'm
different show us right the reason why
it's counterintuitive is because of
these guys right and the fact that we
used to vent be different when you
differentiate yeah so freezes when you
differentiate each of them on their own
okay when you differentiate each of them
on their own are the derivatives the
same and they're the same they're not
right because you'll get one two and
three
okay the reason why is because when you
draw how they look okay so experts at 45
degrees up from the axis apply that how
does 2x look different it's steeper how
does 3x look steeper again okay and
that's why they derivatives are
different okay but what do these look
like and how are they different
do we need to actually draw those if you
drew them you'd see the tutors do match
okay
how could you work it out without
drawing it it was all there we started
the lesson with it in fact because it
wasn't was inability I think was Amelia
start us off actually very conveniently
with the law that we needed that was
just a coincidence I can say that it's
your 7/3 um can anyone see it who's
who's got the wheels wheels turning yeah
can you tell me tell me well how should
i how can I prove like visually or maybe
algebraically to the racer why the dues
are the same
okay let's let's rewind a little because
I think you're right
don't sure if everyone understood you
know princess you said split it how do I
split it
okay good syrup writing here means
that's actually the Sun yes okay you
saying it now so this is this here
here's my 2 X 2 so now when I
differentiate the lot differentiate both
sides some of you may actually remember
you know what this I think it's what 693
blob of something like that okay but the
important thing is not so much what
value it is but that it's it's a value
it's constant okay so when you
differentiate it it just becomes zero
plus the true that
so this is interesting the difference
between these one two three is that the
slope changes okay but the difference
between these because of how logs were
it's just a vertical shift isn't it
this would be this plus more - okay what
about this one it'll be this plus log
three wouldn't it just go a little
higher that's all all right so that's
that there's the mystery solved
I'm going to go in and have a look at
how the chain rule works with log
function because some of the questions
you were having a go at have some quite
involved questions so I'm going to go
back and review that because some of you
were struggling a little bit so you're
fine with it that's okay
but I didn't actually derive the chain
rule with block functions it was a bit
of a seizure
sir make that door subheading and let's
think about a question line
so lesson one start now channeled chain
rule or function and function rule is
the proper name but who likes to say
that these levels chain rule how does it
work well what's the definition of chain
rule I'll give you a clue
it starts with X and equals what now
hold on let's pause for a second I just
said chain rule so I'm thinking about
chain rule with regard to all functions
so completely general so not not pinned
down to polynomials not kidnap the
Exponential's no particular kind of
function any any Y that I like okay what
goes on to here it's the chain in chain
rule do y r-d u times D yes okay good
now that obviously makes the question
what's this new business we'll get to in
a second okay I'm by the way I should
mention because I've been writing it for
a few days now but I haven't really
addressed it I'm not sure if you're
familiar with this but the dot is
multiplication you probably guessed that
already I'm using it now in these Toby
because perhaps everything X is flying
around and for me it's just a bad idea
if I'm actually writing like handwriting
I tend to write my X's like that kind of
in a hurry so it looks just like
multiple pages if any of you brave or
crazy enough to be nuts
at uni you will actually discover that
dog multiplication and cross
multiplication which is what you were
used to writing
are actually totally different things
and future future HSC students actually
probably to discover that more because
it becomes a big deal in a topic called
vectors calculus so when you're looking
at matrices of all that which is in the
new National Curriculum top
multiplication of matrices so for
instance this if this means anything to
you you don't need to know what that is
but that whatever it is is different to
that like my brain anyway I'm just
saying I'm gonna use it for your intense
and purposes multiplying is multiplying
hooray we don't know that they're two
different kinds of everybody but if you
okay now I said I would come back to
what is what this new was I have a why
have an X what's you
we started to do something what what do
we substance you yeah good so in this
case it's this so colloquially you might
call it the inside you're probably right
okay so that's why this is functional
yeah
so let's actually do this substitution
here by the time you get used to using
chain where you don't need to pull out
the full version even if you're
struggling a little bit the beginning
particularly it's worth doing the things
so
now this way you have a choice I
generally now that I have you in an
answer to each other I differentiate
straightaway okay because do you or the
exes half of the pieces that'll mean to
get the dru do you annex dance I'll just
work it out straight away do you on
ecstasy soon - ass good so there's that
part of the chain rule actually resolved
now got this dy do you business I need
to work out that relationship so based
on this substitution I can say y equals
log of U so pretty simple examples of if
you win I've got this piece deep now I
mean that piece dy which we've just
established ears
what are you okay
now I'll do one more step just to make
sure it's all it's all clean and nice
that you use is actually something we
introduced artificially
okay so I'll put it back in terms of X's
the reason why I like to eat that is so
when I come to Hyuna and I actually say
okay what are these two we can doing
integration factors that you should okay
you guys probably know that it's you've
got to be really really careful okay you
got to watch a few have upper and lower
bands and so on so it's a really bad
idea in general to have two different
kinds of variables player at the same
time so I have voyage darkness I avoid
writing this kind of thing
it's it's true but I think it's sort of
not a good habit to get into using exes
flying around when really you really
have one or the other
okay and the whole point is to get rid
of the huge so that's why I did this so
instead I can get it all in terms of one
and of course mentally most of your way
up to the stage where you can just write
that straight away from here because you
can see it's in the form for more
functions F - okay so let's just tie
that up and just link it's a integration
generally speaking the derivative of a
of a log function involving chain rule
okay let's this guy down here okay so
you can simply write it as f - go
straight there you don't need to go
through the whole substitution if it's a
pretty simple question like this if
you're doing function functions and
function it's obviously in your interest
to try and break apart some of that
working so you're not doing it all in
your head but this isn't one by the way
before we leave off finish every time
you know something that differentiation
you equally make a statement about
integration right so if I'm gonna turn
this statement learn to a derivative but
into an interval what would I write
so so this is if you like right sorry
this is the primitive right this is
where it came from and this is what we
ended up with okay so if I just
integrate both sides with respect to X
that's this part F dash with respect to
X what am I going to get the other side
right wrong you're all wrong
wake up what's wrong oh by the way just
in case probably this has been mentioned
to you before but the way that monkey
works at the HSC is that there are no
hot box given for anything even though
you know really tiny little
insignificant errors right little half
marks okay so if you read this off one
of two things will happen
I think you lose a whole mark off say
like a true bug question you'll get one
out of two even if the rest is fire or
if you're lucky nothing will happen
because what will happen is they only
check for the constant of integration on
a single question in the interesting
generally it's in question one so I take
that back question ones are lots of
address that so the question 11 is where
you would see it okay
generally speaking so if you're lucky
you'll miss it if you forget it okay
but if you're not lucky BAM the whole
line goes okay so don't forget it